there may not be a ton of blockbusters
or superhero flicks on tap for February
but there are still more than enough
great movies to keep you busy at your
local theater from future award season
fodder to animated comedies and a few
mid-tier franchise sequels here all the
movies worth checking out on the big
screen in February 2017 rings it's been
about a decade since that wet weirdo
climbed out of a TV and killed a bunch
of people and in the year since that
freaky VHS tape is looking to make the
transition into the digital age
the long-awaited sequel rings comes out
On February 3rd and picks up about 13
years after the first film it follows a
woman and her boyfriend who get roped
into the freaky drama of the horrific
tape and it also aims to deepen the
mythology with a secret message hidden
inside the tape that no one has found
until now a second silver the phone
rings and this boy said the film also
features the tagline first you watch it
then you die
so good luck with that the space between
us
they're star-crossed lovers and then
there's the space between us coming out
on February 3rd this fascinating teen
love story follows a boy boy on Mars and
the earth girl he falls in love with
16-year old gardener lives his entire
life with only the 14 other people on
the red planet
but finally gets a chance to visit earth
and connect with his pen pals
Tulsa of course his visit doesn't go as
planned when he realizes his body can
handle Earth's atmosphere and he embarks
on a whirlwind journey to try and figure
out where he belongs in life and in the
solar system John wick chapter 2 2014
surprise hit John wick proved the Keanu
Reeves was still able to kick butt and
expectations are high that John wick
Chapter two can carry on the trend when
it comes out on February 10 the story
follows Reed's hitmen as he's pulled out
of retirement to help a former associate
take over an Assassin's Guild the
supporting cast includes common Laurence
Fishburne Ricardo's comércio Ruby Rose
John Leguizamo and Ian McShane and the
end result promises to be a bloody
gritty thrill ride oh so long Koecher if
this one works out the studio is already
eyeballing a third film in the franchise
the Lego Batman movie just go ahead when
you're ready sorry I wasn't listening
I've just been bad bailing on my
Batphone yeah can you just do the one we
learned that version of The Dark Knight
was a breakout performance in the lego
movie
so Warner Brothers decided to spin him
off into his own adventure the early
trailers have looked outrageously funny
and the family-friendly CGI tale
promises to roll in a ton of players
from across the Batman and DC Universe
to tell what could be one of the best
Batman stories and years if nothing else
it'll be unlike pretty much every other
DC movie on the market
Superman is my greatest enemy it remains
not a bad guy acts in it I don't
currently have a bad guy I am fighting a
few different people I like to fight
around if you're looking for a break
from Zack Snyder's grim world this
should do it prepare for everything to
be awesome again On February 10th fifty
shades darker the second film in the 50
shades of grey saga arrives on February
10th which stars Dakota Johnson and
Jamie Dornan joined by Kim Basinger
Tyler hoechlin and Hugh Dancy the sequel
picks up with Anna trying to move past
her relationship with Christian but
since the franchise is far from over you
can probably guess they get back
together but this time under a Miskin
dition the critically panned original
movie made a whole lot of money so it'll
be interesting to see what new director
James Foley brings us to e/l James's
bondage tale don't bring your mom or do
if you're weird the Great Wall this
fantasy action flick promises to be one
of the biggest Chinese film productions
in history attracting a-list Hollywood
talent including Matt Damon Willem Dafoe
and Pedro Pascal it's a period adventure
about heroes fighting off giant monsters
during the Song Dynasty so historical
accuracy doesn't really figure anywhere
into this releasing on February 17th
early footage from the film looks like a
white-knuckle throw ride with a whole
lot of monster slaying action
Damon seems to be channeling his Jason
Bourne persona of it but hey who
wouldn't want to see Jason Bourne slug
it out with a giant monster fist fight
if you're a fan of HBO's cult hit Vice
Principals this should be right up your
alley
this ice cube vehicle features the
ride-along star pitted against It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia is Charlie
day as two teachers who are headed
towards an old-fashioned parking lot
brawl
after one accidentally gets the other
fire parking lot after school it's on
today is hilarious and pretty much
anything and the early trailers look
like he'll be an excellent boil to ice
cube style of humor cut class to see
this one On February 17 a cure for
wellness this psychological horror
thriller from acclaimed director gore
verbinski stars Dane DeHaan Mia goth and
Jason Isaacs the story is about a young
executive sent to retrieve his company's
CEO at a Wellness Center where it turns
out the spas healing techniques are a
bit too good to be true before long he
comes down with a mystery illness that
everyone says filed once to cure it
looks to be a twisty and terrifying tale
and it comes out February 17 get out
this racially-charged horror film
scheduled for February 24th was written
and directed by comedian Jordan Peele
who described the project as a horror
movie with a satirical premise the story
follows a young african-american man who
visits the family and the state of his
white girlfriend when many of the black
people in the area start to vanish the
young man realizes this weekend visit is
a lot more dangerous than just meeting
the parents feel is no stranger to
racially charged comedy horror but this
one seems a lot less funny than his
previous effort these are some racist
[ __ ] zombie why would you even
lock the door I mean the windows broken
oh hell no rock dog the CGI tale of a
dog from a small town looking to make it
as a rock star has turned out to be a
box-office dud in its native China but
there's hope US audiences will come out
to see Luke Wilson's anthropomorphic
mutt chase his dream of being a rock
star on February 24th if trying to make
it in music wasn't hard enough
Wilson's pup will also have to contend
with the rogue wolf pack along with
Wilson the film also features the voices
of JK Simmons Louis black Kenan Thompson
Mae Whitman Jorge Garcia and Matt Dillon
collide kicking around development since
2013 collide will make its American
debut on February 24th 2017 after its
German release in 2016 the story tracks
a heist gone wrong leaving a young man
on the run from a dangerous mob boss
played by the imposing Anthony Hopkins
then he turns to his old drug smuggling
employ
played by Ben Kingsley for help all the
while he tries to protects girlfriend
played by rogue ones Felicity Jones with
Jones's star on the rise it might just
be enough to launch this troubled action
flick to a bit more success than
predicted thanks for watching click on
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to